yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing I am gym buddy who the heck is
that bindi Chang ok so the green trails
probably there should be six I had it to
surpass three Nathan I mean it's the
best line probably one of the best lines
with black can play with or inside
remarkable how quick people yes that's a
doctors and that you get it like every
game yeah white set up here looks very
very yes slow come to somehow um yeah
what is that yeah queen bee three is
extremely weak well maybe no can
actually take on c5 twice and play
default that's that's pretty awful
taking only six looks yeah lamer than
lame but what do I plane I have to be
five but the dancer come on I know that
this is not this is not a happy move but
I need to speed up my development I mean
he's got the bishop pair with the bishop
on g7 currently is biting on gwinnett so
of course I don't have anything I don't
have an advantage but I feel
it should be reasonably okay get seem
maybe then no he'll okay anyway
goodnight be sick salsa or look T 391 no
it looks all so strange yeah this is a
good and simple solution yeah yeah he's
got a five coming playing for Queen B
seven
yeah probably you can do yeah that's
probably nothing boonton yeah this
position is equal
it's a tad easier for wyatt because the
e4 pawn is a slight weakness but nothing
nothing to write home about I can now
probably not there are often and
actually no because there is a slight
weakness stem I brings the king
of course it should be a draw I know but
it also it's a little bit about black
structure here I probably cannot do much
is also always but what is this movie
stays on the second-ranked here right I
cannot play King age to hear others
there's nothing that I can do okay so
our answer it let's try sometimes you
can do something again such a pawn on e4
which is a little bit disconnected from
the rest of the position of course it
can be controlled continue here I wonder
if this is an idea is probably not there
are often boom haha yes yes sometimes
and there is there are situations where
this isolated pawn can be something but
it's it's probably not the case here so
this fish should be six line is a is
really a bit of a nuisance it seems that
leg is find them I think c5 is probably
critical there
please h3 is maybe too slow having
looked at this form for a while here
yeah taking on a success of course
basically admitting that you don't have
anything at all but I did not see
anything great young I was thinking
maybe beehives maybe but even now the
engine pointed out even he i didn't see
what i have now I mean if he takes it
this is going to be at least interesting
the point is kind of dangerous but as
also like the fun and I didn't really
didn't really feel like this can be
something if anything here yes there's I
was thinking this move I have my
development is bad so this is why I
decided to do two let's play yeah I know
I cut my losses or something it equal 86
and here I mean maybe there is something
that i can try nice a spoon yes takes a
little bit quickly so this is this look
a three and creme you won the small
precise I have because of threatened
cream be a gem and this is interesting
this this is indeed Bethlehem and I
still have those idea but also queen bee
aid for Bishop f8 Bishop h6 and opinion
so it is a little bit it slightly
awkward for black but Sony hack you
forgetting to switch that on me it's not
much you know it's just like what it's a
good engine is on 0.4
[Music]
can actually change the layout that you
see more yeah some oh I had this set up
a little bit better earlier and somehow
i change the window configuration and
yeah so can I did it like that and here
we're dealing with a completely equal
position and I was trying a little bit
with this with this e for cause there is
nothing that I can do this is important
if I would have gotten here I mean it
still is wrong to separate some hope
yeah so nothing much to do here ok guys
thanks for watching